america's wartime president on the move
joe biden touching down in poland
here the war raged by russia in next
door ukraine feels very close
the risk of spillover all too real
no coincidence then that his first stop
was to see us combat troops based in
this country in ever greater numbers to
deter russian threats
time for a friendly chat and then some
more sobering words
i don't want to sound too philosophic
here but you're in the midst of
a fight between democracies and all and
and oligarchs the question is
who's going to prevail
are democracies going to prevail on the
and the values we share
or autocracy is going to prevail
and that's really what's at stake
so what you're doing is consequential
the tough talk is being heard in the
kremlin with russia's president again
distorting reality and playing victim
they're not trying to cancel our country
i'm talking about the progressive
discrimination of everything to do with
russia this trend that's unfolding in a
number of western states
with the
full
neglect sometimes encouragement of
western cultures
in fact it's president putin's war in
ukraine that's triggered the west's
outrage
though moscow has signaled a scaling
back of its ambitions claiming it'll now
focus on the eastern region of donbass a
far smaller prize than toppling the
government in kiev
lots for president biden to discuss when
he meets his polish counterpart on
saturday including whether to arm
ukraine with more powerful weapons like
tanks and jets
we are in favor of supporting the
ukraine whatever
they
they need
we should
as as nato as the european
union consider what can we offer but
once again it shouldn't be done
[Music]
it should be done jointly another joint
effort is how to care for millions of
ukrainian refugees fleeing the fighting
this vast exhibition hall outside warsaw
has become a transit hub and holding
center for so many broken lives
katya fled the southern port city of
hassan with her two children and niece
she revealed what life is like inside an
area now controlled by russian forces
[Music]
at least now they have sanctuary with
plans to catch a bus to lithuania
brave stoicism everywhere in this place
even among the youngest
debra haynes sky news warsaw